selten zuvor war die politik der
regierung zur erklärungsbedürftig
wesentliche inhalte kannten wir aber
bereits nicht erst seit der
pressekonferenz vom gestrigen abend bei
der unterrichtung der
fraktionsvorsitzenden denn vorgestern
bereits haben medien berichtet über das
was das bundeskanzleramt mit den
landesregierungen besprechen will
während gestern das parlament hier
getagt hat und sich mit anderen dingen
beschäftigt hat war für die breite
öffentlichkeit die
entscheidungsgrundlage der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bereits im
internet zum download verfügbar
ich rate ab frau merkel diesen umgang
mit dem parlament zur ständigen
staatspraxis werden zu lassen
aus gutem grund haben drei fraktionen
dieses hauses deshalb dazu geraten und
dringend darum gebeten dass sie vor der
runde mit den ländern den deutschen
bundestag über ihre absichten und
grundlinien unterrichten
damit haben wir nichts unmögliches
verlangt denn im vorfeld des
europäischen rates entspricht das der
praxis der regierung und entspricht dem
umgang der regierung mit diesem
parlament das hätte die möglichkeit
geboten das sie ihre maßnahmenvorschläge
darstellen es hätte die chance eröffnet
auch die wissenschaftlichen grundlagen
zu hinterfragen und es wäre vor allen
dingen darum gegangen alternative
strategien hier in die debatte
einzubringen
sie haben diese möglichkeit leider
ausgeschlagen dabei wäre es eine chance
auch für ihre regierung gewesen um
verständnis und vertrauen der menschen
zu werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
es unverändert mit einer gefährlichen
pandemie zu tun
wer die gefahren die mit der kogit
erkrankung verbunden sind relativiert
der handelt fahrlässig oder gar
vorsätzlich aber wir leben nun auch ein
jahr in und mit dieser pandemie
wir haben wie die frau bundeskanzlerin
gesagt hat gelernt die infektionszahlen
gehen zurück
es gibt zu langsame und zu beschwerlich
aber immerhin fortschritte bei den
impfungen und deshalb und angesichts der
grossen erschöpfung in unserer
gesellschaft waren die erwartungen an
die gestrige runde groß diese hoffnungen
sind enttäuscht worden denn viele
menschen haben sich mehr erwartet als
einen frischen haarschnitt
der wesentlicher ansatz ihrer strategie
findet sich auch in dieser vorlage ich
zitiere der grundsatz wir bleiben zu
hause bleibt das wesentliche instrument
im kampf gegen die pandemie zitat ende
wirklich auch nach einem jahr noch trotz
allem was wir gelernt haben hangeln wir
uns seit oktober november von einem lock
down von einem gipfel zum nächsten ohne
eine klare perspektive
das ist bestenfalls einfallslos mit
sicherheit frau merkel ist das nicht
alternativlos
christiane woopen die vorsitzende des
europäischen ethik rates in diesem haus
von vielen sehr geschätzt und mit
sicherheit eine verantwortungsbewusste
und umsichtige persönlichkeit hat dieser
tage in einem interview folgendes gesagt
ich zitiere seit einem jahr drehen sich
diese runden fast unverändert um das
gleiche den lock down
ich halte es für dringend erforderlich
eine perspektive zu eröffnen statt
durchhalteparolen zu verkünden und
weiter erhoben
ich habe kein verständnis mehr dafür
dass man vorhandene technologien nicht
nutzt
wir haben dafür auch kein verständnis
mehr frau merkel warum orientieren wir
uns nicht antun wie tübingen oder
rostock wo sind die wirksam und hier im
hause oft genug angemahnten strategien
zum wirklichen schutz der hohen erwerben
gruppen und zwar nicht nur ein alten und
pflegeheim sondern auch etwa durch die
oft hier angemahnten exklusiven
zeitfenster für den einkauf oder taxi
gutscheine
wo ist die bereit sich initiative
luftfilter in die praxis zu bringen wo
setzen wir systematisch schnelltests ein
und warum wurde die korona vanek mit
großen erwartungen öffentlich
vorgestellt und danach technologisch
ein bisschen weiterentwickelt deshalb
bleiben wir hinter unseren möglichkeiten
zurück und deshalb orientieren wir uns
ausschließlich auf den stillstand statt
auch mit der bedrohung durch das virus
neue möglichkeiten für
gesellschaftliches leben zu eröffnen und
die werden wir brauchen denn wir können
uns nicht sicher sein dass dies die
einzige zu hause ist mit der die
menschheit in den nächsten jahren
umzugehen hat wir können uns noch nicht
mal sicher sein ob es nicht der einzelne
mutation geben könnte dieser erkrankung
auf die die impfung eben nicht mehr die
wirksame antwort ist mindestens nicht
mit den vorhandenen impfstoffen
also brauchen wir jetzt methoden und
eine infrastruktur mit der wir die
pandemie besser ausbalancieren mit dem
gesundheitsschutz der notwendig ist aber
der freiheit die die menschen auch leben
müssen
über monate haben wir uns an der zahl 50
nach den instanzen orientiert obwohl sie
eine politische setzung ist obwohl
oberbürgermeister auch
cdu-oberbürgermeister sagen
selbstverständlich können sie auch mehr
als 50 infektion 100.000 einwohner in
der woche inzwischen nachverfolgen
wir haben uns auf diese zahl von 50 in
deutschland fixiert und nun wird sie
ersetzt durch die 35 in der zentralen
bedeutung und wir wissen dass im
kanzleramt auch schon über die 10 als
zahl gesprochen worden ist
dadurch dass die wesentliche
entscheidungsgrundlage ausgetauscht wird
ohne vorbereitung ohne klare
argumentation gefährden sie die
akzeptanz der maßnahmen in der
bevölkerung insgesamt
wo ist die berechenbarkeit
im infektionsschutzgesetz übrigens wird
ausdrücklich auch ein regionaler zugang
angemahnt im von der großen koalition
beschlossenen infektionsschutzgesetz
wird angemahnt regional zu
differenzieren
tatsächlich haben wir heute bereits eine
vielzahl von landkreisen unter 50
darunter 35 und trotzdem gelten dort die
gleichen beschränkungen wie in den hot
hot spots mit über 200 incidents da ist
bereits der zweifel an der
verhältnismäßigkeit angelegt von
bundeskanzlerin
es ist richtig kitas und schulen zu
öffnen aber auch in ihrer
regierungserklärung hier haben sie
gerade deutlich gemacht mit recht
hinhaltenden widerstand aus dem
kanzleramt dies erfolgt herr kretschmann
hat das in der runde dem vernehmen nach
gestern auch angesprochen warum stellt
frau carlitscheck finanziert mit
öffentlichen fördergeldern in dieser
woche eine wissenschaftliche studie vor
unter welchen bedingungen mit welchem
paket an maßnahmen in der pandemie die
förderung von kindern und jugendlichen
in kitas und schulen möglich ist wenn
die eigenen empfehlungen des
bundesbildungsministeriums im
bundeskanzleramt nicht ernst genommen
werden sie öffnen die friseure
sie öffnen die friseure obwohl das eine
so genannte körpernahe dienstleistung
ist man sich wirklich nun sehr nahe
kommt beim haarschnitt das ermöglichen
sie war sie weil sie sagen gut da gibt
es hygiene konzepte da wird die maske
getragen und deshalb ist es
verantwortbar den friseur zu öffnen das
ist richtig aber gibt es solche hygiene
konzepte nur bei den friseuren nicht in
gleicher weise im sport in
fitnessstudios die auch gesundheits
präventive wirkung haben gibt es diese
gesundheitskonzepte nicht auch im
bereich der kosmetik sind sie
ausgeschlossen beim handel gar in der
gastronomie sind solche gene konzepte
denkbar
deshalb trägt die entscheidung für die
friseure
bereits den makel einer nicht
systematischen ausnahme was wir brauchen
ist eine systematik klarer wenn dann
regeln weil nur dass die berechenbarkeit
für die menschen und übrigens auch für
die behörden bringt diese systematik im
wege eines stufenplans war von ihnen vor
drei wochen ja bereits auch angekündigt
worden
diese arbeitsgruppe einzige tag hatte
kein ergebnis
wir haben deshalb in dieser woche einen
7 stufenplan vorgelegt mit welcher
systematik es möglich ist regional zu
öffnen
und dieser von uns vorgelegten
stufenplan ist natürlich getragen von
unseren grundüberzeugungen vielleicht
stärker als andere fraktionen hier im
haus setzen ihr vertrauen in die
eigenverantwortung der menschen und
setzen wir darauf dass es für große
probleme auch innovative technische
lösungen gibt das muss nicht jeder
teilen
aber es gibt eben auch andere stufen
pläne innerhalb der landesregierung von
rheinland pfalz mit sozialdemokratie und
den grünen wird darüber nachgedacht die
landesregierung von schleswig-holstein
mit union und grünen und fdp war die
erste die einen solchen stufenplan
vorgelegt hat wem also unser stufenplan
der hier liberalen charakter hat zu weit
gehend ist der findet mit unterstützung
der eigenen kolleginnen und kollegen in
den ländern auch politische alternativen
dass sie als bundesregierung dennoch und
tätig geworden sind und den einmal nicht
erfüllten arbeitsauftrag einfach in die
zukunft fortschreiben das zeigt dass sie
in wahrheit gar kein interesse an einem
solchen perspektiv plan haben so
notwendig er auch ist deshalb verehrte
anwesende meine damen und herren ist
diese regierungserklärung eine
enttäuschung sie ist bedauerlicherweise
nur ein weiter so und mein letzter
gedanke wenn sie schon den locker und
jetzt weiter verschärfen wer weiß wie
lang dann passen sie ihre
wirtschaftlichen hilfen auch an ein
schweres versäumnis
dass die sozialdemokratie und herr
scholz immer noch nicht ihren widerstand
aufgegeben haben gegen das
unbürokratisch schnellste und wirksamste
instrument betriebe und selbständige zu
unterstützen nämlich den vollen
steuerlichen verlust rück tag und zwar
auf die ganzen letzten jahre seit 2000
soweit also fdp chef christian lindner
darüber werden wir auch gleich natürlich
noch sprechen wollen uns jetzt aber auch
noch anhören die rede von ralph
brinkhaus erst position der cdu und csu
bundestagsfraktion wir sehen jetzt auch
noch einmal wurde natürlich das
rednerpult desinfiziert jetzt wegen der
korona masse natürlich und jetzt also
reif brinkhaus von der cdu und csu
fraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren
herr lindner die zahl 50 und auch die
zahl 35 die stehenden § 28a
infektionsschutzgesetz hier im deutschen
bundestag beschlossen und sind insofern
nicht willkürlich und das zu ihrer
behauptung der deutsche bundestag wäre
hier nicht beteiligt meine damen und
herren
wenn wir uns die entwicklung der letzten
wochen und monate angucken da muss man
sagen der locker und wirkt wir kommen
von instanzen vor neue infektionszahlen
von knapp 200 wir sind jetzt unter 65
das heißt die maßnahmen haben gewirkt
und wir liegen übrigens auch im
europäischen vergleich mit unseren
neuinfektionen sehr sehr gut besser als
viele viele andere länder besser als
vielen nachbarländern wir liegen auch
insgesamt noch sehr gut bei der anzahl
der infizierten auf 100000 einwohner und
auch ja bei der anzahl der toten auf
100000 einwohner was schlecht ist und
das gehört zur wahrheit leider auch dazu
ist die anzahl der toten bei den
hochbetagten das ist eine sache wo wir
uns als gesellschaft fragen müssen ob
wir dort alles richtig gemacht haben
diese kolleginnen
meine damen und herren das war jetzt
sehr interessant jetzt sagt herr lindner
da muss die cdu sich fragen
also ich finde schon sehr sehr
interessant wie sie mit dieser krise
umgehen wie sie versuchen
parteipolitisch kapital zu schlagen wie
sie versuchen wahlkampf zu machen in der
schwersten krise die diese republik hat
es ist erbärmlich erleben und die bilder
rinnen und bilder zeigen es ihnen auch
bei den umfragen dass das nicht
verschenkt was sie hier veranstalten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir sind beim thema impfen auch zu
langsam aber mittlerweile ins rollen
gekommen und wir sind auch beim thema
wirtschafts hilfen und das muss man an
dieser stelle auch sagen viel viel
umfangreicher unterwegs als die meisten
anderen länder und ja herr mütze nicht
da gehört auch das kurzarbeitergeld dazu
dazu gehörten vereinfachter zugang bei
hartz iv dazu es ist ein gesamtpaket
dass wir im bereich wirtschaft auf den
weg gebracht haben und es ist gut dass
die überbrückungshilfe drei jetzt auch
ausgezahlt wird liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und für all diejenigen die
jetzt sagen ja aber in anderen ländern
ist es besser ja andere länder haben
andere umstände australien ist eine
insel und wir können uns gerne mal die
repressionsmaßnahmen in china angucken
ob wir die hier haben wollen und im
übrigen ist es so dass andere länder
auch nicht so viele hochbetagte haben
wie wir
aber eins ist auch richtig alle länder
die besser durch die pandemie gekommen
sind als wir haben zuerst einen
radikalen lockt onkel hat und haben
zuerst die zahlen nach unten geknüppelt
nach unten geprügelt und deswegen ist es
auch richtig was wir hier machen dass
wir sagen bevor wir in differenzierte
maßnahmen einsteigen müssen wir erst die
zahlen nach unten kriegen und das ist
genau die politik die jetzt auch gestern
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
entsprechend weitergeführt wird und
diese politik die ist richtig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und
deswegen ist es auch freud zu
unterstützen dass die knock down
maßnahmen weitergeführt werden sorgen
bereitet mir allerdings auch wenn es in
unserem grundgesetz vorgesehen ist dass
die länder individuell darüber
entscheiden die schulen und die kitas
wieder zu öffnen
ich habe da meine zweifel ob das in
dieser phase richtig ist weil wenn wir
mal uns betrachten wo wir herkommen und
die bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt wir
kommen von instanzen unter 10 unter 5
und da müssen wir auch wieder hin um
entsprechend die öffnung hin zu kriegen
natürlich ist es sehr sehr hart für die
schülerinnen und schüler für die eltern
für die familien und das erkennen wir
auch anders es hat es es ist eine
zumutung aber es ist auch eine zumutung
dass mehr als 60.000 menschen in diesem
land gestorben sind liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen oder auch das muss man
immer wieder im hinterkopf behalten will
dann über freiheitsrechte redet und ich
bleibe dabei herr lindner was ich hier
vor einigen wochen gesagt habe freiheit
ist auch immer die freiheit der
schwachen und nicht nur die freiheit der
starken liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
aber wenn wir einmal nach vorne schauen
dann reicht das ja jetzt nicht dass
ministerpräsidenten dass das
bundeskabinett das wir hier uns klar
darüber sind wie es entsprechend weiter
geht sondern es gibt eine menge die noch
dinge die noch zu tun sind
ich möchte ihnen fünf dinge nennen wo
wir jetzt ran müssen das erste ist das
thema schulen ja es ist die
länderkompetenz aber trotzdem erwarte
ich gerade vor dem hintergrund dass
jetzt wieder öffnungen auf den weg
gebracht werden test strategien lüftung
strategien logistik strategien dass die
schulbusse nicht mehr so voll sind beim
thema schulen erwarte ich dass es eine
lernstandserhebung gibt was ist verpasst
worden
das ist konzepte dafür gibt über den
sommer hinweg durch nachhilfe durch
sommerakademie wie dieser stoff
aufgeholt werden kann
das ist konzepte dafür gibt wie
insbesondere die kinder gefördert werden
die in benachteiligten familien
aufwachsen wo nicht geholfen werden kann
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
gehört natürlich auch dazu ich glaube
wir haben im bereich schule sehr sehr
viel zu tun
der zweite bereich gesundheitsämter das
rückgrat unserer pandemie bekämpfung
sind die gesundheitsämter ja wir haben
einen pakt für das öffentliche
gesundheitswesen ja wir haben mehr geld
bereitgestellt aber dieses geld muss
jetzt auch entsprechend umgesetzt werden
die software frage muss schnell gelöst
werden wir müssen die prozesse
analysieren und wir brauchen eine
monitoringstelle wo die qualität der
gesundheitsämter auch tatsächlich
kontrolliert wird sonst können sie nicht
das rückgrat der bekämpfung der pandemie
sein und dazu gehört ja auch eine
adäquate bezahlung der mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter in den gesundheitsämtern
dritter großer bereich altenheime wir
haben jetzt viele erfolge erzielt beim
impfen der hochbetagten menschen die in
den altenheimen wohnen
wir brauchen aber eine weiterführende
strategie was ist mit den menschen die
jetzt neu aufgenommen werden die noch
nicht geimpft sind wo gibt es da das
konzept das flächendeckend
sichergestellt wird dass derjenige der
neue in einem altenheim aufgenommen wird
auch geimpft wird wie führen wir die
tests strategien weiter
es reicht ja jetzt nicht zu sagen alle
sind geimpfte und alles ist gut und vor
allen dingen müssen wir eins machen und
das habe ich eben schon mal gesagt und
das ist das große problem was wir in
dieser pandemie gehabt haben warum sind
so viele menschen in den
nur pflegeheimen gestorben was ist dort
falsch gemacht worden und zwar nicht
unbedingt auf den finger zu mit dem
finger auf irgendjemand zu zeigen
sondern um die dinge auch in die zukunft
besser zu lösen und vor allen dingen
auch eine höhere sicherheit für die
menschen dort zu erzielen
vierter bereich impfen ja wir schaffen
jetzt mehr impfstoff das ist gut
wir brauchen eine zweite sache wir
brauchen ein besseres impftermin vergabe
management was in einigen bundesländern
in den letzten wochen passiert ist das
80 jährige über 80 jahre in
telefonschleifen tagelang fest gehangen
haben dass sie in online schleifen
festgesessen haben das ist nicht
akzeptabel und das ist würde und
respektlos gegenüber den alten menschen
in diesem land und wenn wir über das
thema impfen reden dann müssen wir uns
auch darauf vorbereiten dass diese
pandemie nicht vorbei ist dass wir
vielleicht nach kämpfen müssen dass wir
noch mal impfen müssen dass die nächste
pandemie kommt und deswegen brauchen wir
eine impfstrategie 20 22 und 1 haben wir
gelernt
bei aller wertschätzung für
globalisierte wertschöpfungsketten
wir brauchen eine im produktions
autarkie innerhalb der europäischen
union
wenn wir nicht in der lage sind unseren
impfstoff selbst herzustellen
dann werden wir immer abhängig sein von
anderen regierungen von anderen regionen
und dafür ist die frage zu ernst um ein
thema impfen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen möchte ich auch noch einen
punkt hinweisen
wir tun ja immer hier so als wenn das
hier hat es so langsam ist nicht schnell
genug geht und das mag vielleicht auch
richtig sein aber die meisten länder in
dieser welt impfen noch gar nicht
insbesondere schwellenländer
insbesondere länder in der dritten welt
und ich glaube wir haben die
verpflichtung die moralische
verpflichtung dass wir auch impfstoff
weltweit zur verfügung stellen und wir
sollten nicht nur an uns denken sondern
wir sollten auch an die welt denken wenn
wir über
das thema in frieden und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es gibt noch
einen weiteren punkt und da können wir
nicht warten bis die pandemie vorbei ist
wobei ich sowieso die befürchtung habe
wenn die pandemie vorbei ist dann werden
wir uns wieder anderen dingen zuwenden
und nicht den katastrophen nicht den
dingen die auf uns zukommen können denn
diese pandemie wird nicht die letzte
katastrophe seien sie wird nicht die
letzte pandemie seien die nächste
katastrophe kann im cyber bereich
stattfinden können klimafolgen sein wie
dürre wie hochwasser und viele andere
sachen
und wir haben eigentlich die mechanismen
dass wir eine risikoanalyse machen ja
wir hatten auch eine risikoanalyse zu
pandemien aber wir haben sie nicht ernst
genug genommen und dementsprechend
müssen wir uns intensiver auch mit einer
katastrophenvorsorge beschäftigen wir
haben auch nicht die gesetzlichen
grundlagen ich bin der meinung dass der
deutsche bundestag sehr sehr gut und
vernünftig mit der sache umgegangen ist
dass wir gesetzliche grundlagen in
kurzer zeit geschaffen haben aber wir
müssen uns grund ständig damit
beschäftigen was ist denn bei nationalen
notstand
wir haben eine notstandsgesetzgebung im
wesentlichen für den verteidigungsfall
aber wir glauben doch alle nicht also
dass die gerichte große katastrophe in
diesem land der verteidigungsfall sein
wird sondern das wird was anderes sein
und ja wir müssen das verhältnis
exekutive und legislative aufklären und
definieren und zwar für alle
katastrophen und für alle nationalen und
europäischen notstände und wir müssen
meine lieben kolleginnen und kollegen 1
machen
wir müssen wir müssen uns besser darauf
vorbereiten wir haben super
katastrophenstäbe in den einzelnen
landkreisen und in den städten
wir sind super regional aufgestellt mit
den feuerwehren mit den
hilfsorganisationen aber die bund länder
koordination die operative bund länder
koordination bei katastrophen 24 stunden
7 tage in der woche ständige
katastrophenstäbe stäbe die auch üben
meine damen und herren die bundeswehr
hat 70 jahre geübt dass irgendwelche
panzer an unserer grenze stehen
sie sind gott sei dank ich gekommen wir
müssen katastrophen üben wir müssen
automatismen schaffen dass wir mit
diesen katastrophen besser klarkommen
darum geht es jetzt und das muss die
lehre aus dieser pandemie seien
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
insofern haben wir sehr sehr
viel noch zu tun und wir sollten das
angehen wir müssen jetzt alles dafür tun
dass diese pandemie aufhört aber ehrlich
gesagt diese krise wäre eine vergeudete
krise wenn wir nicht daraus lernen wir
müssen lernen und einige punkte habe ich
ihnen aufgezeigt vielen dank eine sehr
hitzige debatte die wir da gerade erlebt
haben genau darüber möchte ich jetzt
brechen mit meinem kollegen peter tiede
für uns auch meinem bundestag und hier
bei uns im studio jan schäfer peter wie
hast du das gerade erlebt vor allem
natürlich die letzten zwei beiträge die
wir da gehört haben waren ja doch sehr
emotional
ja das wird mal wieder bundestag das
waren debatte da sind zwei sachen
aufeinandergeprallt nämlich einmal
christian lindner mit seiner wirklich
fundamental kritik an der kanzlerin mit
der ihr vorgeworfen hat ihre politik sei
bestenfalls einfallslos auf jeden fall
aber nicht alternativlos und dann die
retourkutsche jedenfalls am anfang
seiner rede von ralph brinkhaus den
fraktions chef der
unions-bundestagsfraktion der christen
als sich ganz kurz aber heftig vor
vorgenommen hat und das aber wieder
richtig richtig bundestag da prallen
sachen aufeinander so wie sich das in
einer ordentlichen debatte auch gehört
damit wir wissen wer auf welcher seite
steht wer wofür streitet und vor allem
auch wie sich die leute miteinander
auseinandersetzen dann du hattest ja
schon am anfang hier einmal gesagt auf
christian lindner müssen wir auf jeden
fall belegten denn er findet immer sehr
deutliche worte wie hast du jetzt also
seine rede vor allem empfunden
ja das war eine klassische rede eines
fast schon muss man sagen
oppositionsführers also desjenigen der
war sie chefin offizieller chef der vier
oppositionspartei im bundestag ist das
war angriffslustig man hat auch gemerkt
die kanzlerin hat zugehört in gewisser
weise wenn es dann etwas zu arg wurde
hat sie auf ihr handy geschaut oder mit
dem vizekanzler und finanzminister olaf
scholz gesprochen und 1 hat christian
lindner hier natürlich vorgeworfen peter
hat es gerade schon gesagt es ist nicht
in ordnung aus seiner sicht und aus
sicht vieler vieler oppositionspolitiker
das papiere im vorfeld des gipfels nicht
auch im bundestag oder den
bundestagsabgeordneten zur verfügung
stehen klar wir journalisten freuen uns
dass wir papiere haben
bild.de und bei bild live und auch in
der bild zeitung
konnte man ja gestern schon lesen was
dann auch am abend beschlossen wurde
vollkommen richtig und wir freuen uns
darüber diese papiere zu haben aber ganz
klar ist da verstehe ich auch den frust
der politiker im bundestag warum wird
eigentlich vorher nicht im bundestag
über diese ganzen fragen debattiert
warum auch das kanzleramt da ein so
großes geheimnis draus und kommt dann
quasi überfallartig abends um 20 uhr mit
einer pressekonferenz und erläutert die
beschlüsse für alle die nicht woher
schon bild live gespielt weise oder auch
bild.de dabei waren
das ist eigentlich keine politik für für
eine demokratie das muss man ganz klar
sagen es nutzt sich auch ab wie gesagt
diese mp cars sind so aus der mode wie
die zdf hitparade und das hat ralph
brinkhaus den fraktionschef merkels
fraktionschef muss man ja sagen massiv
auf die palme getrag getrieben das ist
sowieso schon eine hassliebe zwischen
christian lindner und ralph brinkhaus
haben in den vergangenen monaten immer
wieder erlebt diese beiden kommen nicht
mehr zusammen das wird also keine liebe
mehr werden falls sie im september
miteinander koalieren sollten union fdp
kann man sagen das ist auf jeden fall
einen eintopf paar das das wird keine
liebe mehr werden und da ist die große
hitzige debatte die wir jetzt
hoffentlich weiter sehr christian
lindner hatte auch die friseure noch mal
angesprochen ist natürlich für jeden
froh dass er jetzt wieder seinen
lebensunterhalt durch eine öffnung
wieder finanzieren kann trotzdem hat er
auch gesagt viele verstehen nicht warum
es nur die friseure sind andere
kosmetikstudios würde es gerne
autohäuser die gastro das eine frage die
noch immer offen ist für die es auch
gestern und heute eigentlich noch keine
erklärung gab es absolut richtig also
die kaufhäuser sagen ja beispielsweise
auf großen großen platz ist es viel
besser möglich abstände einzuhalten die
sogenannten aha regeln zu erfüllen das
ist viel einfacher als man das
beispielsweise beim friseur machen kann
wo ja wirklich dann hautkontakt quasi
gesteht das friseur in dieser ganzen
corona pandemie so eine also schon im
ersten block daran wann friseure die
über die wir alle gesprochen ob ich
meine jeder von uns will frisiert sein
aber mir scheint das ja nicht das erste
worauf man eigentlich kommen wir nun
trotzdem haben sie sowohl in der
berichterstattung bei uns natürlich aber
auch in der politik eine herausgestellte
rolle
also ich glaube das geht da gibt es auch
ein bisschen um was persönliches ich war
jetzt selbst seit mehr als drei monaten
nicht mehr beim friseur man sieht wir
leider auch an
und das treibt natürlich viele um so auf
der anderen seite kann man sagen wenn
man neun
aber braucht beispielsweise eine neue
hose dann kann man sich die auch per
internet bestellen also der druck für
uns menschen die sache damals die
konsumenten sich etwas zu bestellen oder
das oder einkaufen zu gehen und etwas
neues zu bekommen der ist nicht so hoch
weil wir das über das internet machen
können das ist anders natürlich bei so
dienstleistungen wie dem friseur das
nervt wenn man einfach zuviel wolle auf
dem kopf hat frau schwesig hat ja auch
schon mal erzählt ihr wuschelkopf der
müsste jetzt quasi kürzer werden das ist
etwas das kann man nicht im internet
bestellen das kann man nur von person zu
person bekommen und da besteht natürlich
ein unterschied was nicht bedeutet dass
diejenigen die jetzt im lock down sind
beispielsweise einzelhändler oder auch
die besitzer von autohäuser oder
fitnessstudios dass die jetzt sozusagen
menschen zweiter klasse während nein
sind sie nicht und genau wie christian
lindner gesagt hat es gibt genügend
hygiene konzepte und es gibt auch genug
platz beim autohaus beispielsweise
findet der einkauf ja meistens draußen
sogar stadt also wo ist das problem
autohäuser zu eröffnen das erschließt
sich mir auch nicht